Hawkeye is coming to disney plus starring
jeremy renner and introducing a new character
into the mcu kate bishop she's a new young
mentee that he can train to eventually
take over the mantle as hawkeye one day and we'll
explore more of his time as ronin in this series
ladies and gentlemen hawkeye himself jeremy renner
this is so amazing what i get to do in the show
ultimately is shepherd an amazing character
to be ultimately probably a better version
of me and the sentiment of what that is
is what i think the fiber of what hawkeye
is this is a superhero without super powers
that means everyone's a superhero this
is what disney plus is doing for the mcu
it is growing it is expanding
it thank you thank you so much
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new avengers hawkeye teaser trailer video
and breakdown of that first look of Hailee
steinfeld as kate bishop so we got so much
information we also found out what's happening
with black widow during the hawkeye series as well
so i'll explain that during the videos i'm talking
about easter eggs if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a new giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post all your theories about the avengers
hawkeye series on the video so if you didn't see
it yesterday it was all over social media we just
got our first official look at the new avengers
endgame hawkeye spin-off series that's coming
to disney plus by the end of next year they just
started filming episodes they're supposed to start
releasing them around this time next year at the
end of 2021 during that we got our first look at
jeremy renner and Hailee Steinfeld officially
confirming that she would be kate bishop in the
mcu pretty much everybody was reporting last year
that she was going to be kate bishop but this is
the first actual confirmation that we've seen of
her on said she'd been teasing it on social media
for the past couple of days making all kinds of
posts that made us think that she was kate bishop
and jeremy renner had been posting some kate
bishop stuff but here she comes running down
the subway staircase with hawkeye and pizza dog in
tow if you have not read the matt fraction hawkeye
run from the comics i would recommend checking it
out because it's badass but it's the story that
they're doing for the series mostly they have to
update it so that it fits with the pre-existing
mcu hawkeye avengers end game storyline so far
but mostly it's going to be fractions run most of
the villains that i'll talk about in a second are
from fractions run if you don't know who pizza dog
is either he's actually going to be really cool
during the series during the fraction run some
of the villains are called the tracksuit mafia
they have a dog called arrow this dog here during
a mission hawkeye goes after the tracksuit mafia
arrow the dog turns on his mafioso masters winds
up saving hawkeye's life and then the mafia throws
the dog into traffic in retaliation hawkeye rushes
to save him rescues him and takes him in and
renames him lucky so even though we call him pizza
dog his actual full name technically is lucky
the pizza dog because hawkeye feeds him pizza
all the time and kate bishop too when she comes
along kate bishop is more of a young avengers
character so i will address the young avengers
stuff that they're setting up with the disney plus
series during the video as well but the villains
for the series that they've announced so far are
the tracksuit mafia madame mask i believe in a
villain called clown he's also part of this hulk
gamma storyline so that might be an indication of
how they're planning on weaving in the thunderbolt
ross thunderbolts weapon plus storyline for marvel
phase 4 that's supposed to start during the black
widow movie in falcon and winter soldier i know
we're all wondering if they're going to work up
to red hulk at some point they're just starting
with weapons plus right now and the super soldier
program coming back eventually that'll lead to a
lot more easter eggs like weapon x the new version
of wolverine once they do the new versions of
the x-men characters in the mcu way down the road
number four so during the Hailee Steinfeld hawkeye
scene they're running down the steps with lucky
the pizza dog she has her giant bow in the other
hand and she's wearing her trademark purple
although the way she's dressed this seems maybe
like an early version of her costume before she
gets her actual comic book costume there will be
some time jumps during the series and flashbacks
to the five years between avengers infinity war
the snap when hawkeye lost his family and then the
beginning of avengers end game to cover hawkeye's
untold story as ronin they said that they would
cover a lot of that during the hawkeye series they
didn't say whether or not he'd be meeting kate
bishop for the first time during that five-year
period when he was ronin or if he meets her for
the first time after avengers end game but i'll
explain in a second there's some easter eggs that
kind of give us an idea for that and a lot of it
has to do with kate bishop's backstory it's very
possible that she meets him as ronin for the first
time before she meets him as hawkeye later on so
number three kate bishop actually grew up a rich
girl the daughter of this wealthy businessman who
was kind of this dirtbag who gets involved
with the mafia bunch of organized crime
she gets really suspicious of him tails him one
day to find out what he's into and gets caught up
with one of the villains he's meeting with but she
winds up being rescued by hawkeye and the avengers
when they show up to trash the villains but she's
so inspired when she sees hawkeye save her and be
such a badass that she decides to get her act
together and stop being this spoiled rich girl
trains herself to fight becomes a vigilante
eventually becoming pretty decent with a bow
enough to join the young avengers so mostly
when she debuted in the comics for the first
time she was a young avengers character
they just referred to as the female archer
but then a long time after that after a couple
more big avengers events hawkeye decides to train
her as his successor and that's when the matt
fraction hawkeye run picks up so number two early
theory what's probably going to be different about
mcu hawkeye and kate bishop is that she's still
this spoiled rich girl who hawkeye just winds up
saving inadvertently but because this whole thing
during that five-year time jump when he was ronin
was going around killing the mafia dismantling
cartels and gangs who didn't get snapped by thanos
odds are pretty good that during one of those
summary executions i think is what war machine was
calling them hawkeye going around executing people
okay bishop just happens to be one of those hits
being held as a victim that he winds up saving
inadvertently and she just sees him tear everyone
to shreds as ronin getting inspired to become a
vigilante herself like oh look at this badass i
should do this too then avengers end game happens
don't give me hope black widow dies natasha black
widow but he gets his family back and because
originally he had actually chosen retirement
in his deal with thunderbolt ross after captain
america civil war that's the whole reason why he
wasn't around for that first fight with thanos
in avengers infinity war now that he got his
family back with the hulk's infinity gauntlet
snap in avengers end game he probably wants to
get back to living out his retirement with them
but because the hulk's snap also brought back a
ton of bad people with the good people there's
still a need for hawkeye ronin to go around taking
care of all these mafia the cartels these avengers
villains all over the world so early prediction
after avengers end game he finds out that the
random rich girl from before is a vigilante now
and decides to take her under his wing and train
her to become the next hawkeye so that he can
fully retire finally but getting into the black
widow crossover stuff so there's supposed to be a
black widow cameo and it's supposed to be yelling
a bulova black widow they're supposed to reference
budapest again to connect with the events of the
black widow movie and address natasha black
widow's death in a bigger way because remember
they didn't even have a funeral for her during
avengers end game the elena belova black widow
is also supposed to show up during the falcon
and winter soldier series as well so i think
that's more confirmation that she's going to get
tied up in a thunderbolts crossover but when she
shows up on the hawkeye series they'll just
tease what her relationship with hawkeye is
going to be how it's going to be different from
natasha's relationship with him because they were
basically like brother and sister they were family
and also because the avengers became like a family
so they'll probably just have some fun with that
like how come you let her die he'll have to answer
for letting her die during avengers end game they
haven't said much more about what's going on with
their young avengers crossover because kate bishop
is a founding member of the young avengers and
we've already found out about several of the
other young avengers characters showing up on
disney plus series like they're literally filming
the miss marvel series right now she's another
young avengers character we have the cassie lang
stature who's coming back as a big character
during ant-man 3 so because all the disney plus
series are crossing over with the movies obviously
Hailee Steinfeld is going to show up in the marvel
movies it's possible that the first marvel movie
that she appears in winds up being ant-man 3
for more continuation on the young avengers
setup story line i'm totally happy with the Hailee
Steinfeld casting i feel like she'll knock it out
of the park i loved her during bumblebee jeremy
renner hasn't said a whole lot about how many
other marvel movies he wants to appear in but
don't be surprised if he comes back in cameos
in some future marvel movies as well because chris
hemsworth's thor is going to be in avengers 5 he's
going to keep doing more movies after thor
4. he's not going away but i know you're all
wondering about the bombshell that warner brothers
dropped this morning as me making this video all
of their movies they announced in 2021 every
single one of them will be releasing on hbo max
just like wonder woman 1984. it is totally
crazy but now everyone's just waiting to see
what disney does with all their movies in 2021 i
would expect something similar where they release
stuff in theaters then within like a week or two
they start dropping stuff on disney plus but post
all your reactions in the comments below obviously
my new mandalorian season 2 episode 6 video will
post on friday just like normal everyone click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 5
ahsoka tano video and click here for my new thor
4 teaser in that big guardians of the galaxy
3 announcement thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!